So during that period of time I was
obsessed is a good word
with
a question in the question was why would
human beings produced two camps
and then
produce a massive arsenal of hydrogen
bombs and I don't know what you know
about hydrogen bombs,
but they have atom bombs for triggers
and you know,
that's where thinking about,
because an atom bomb,
you know,
hey,
that's,
that's something but a hydrogen bomb,
that's the son that's really something.
So,
and you know,
there's 20 there at,
at,
at the peak of the Cold War and there's,
this is still true to some degree.
There were literally tens of thousands
of these weapons aimed at the Soviet
Union then at the West.
And that was enough to pretty much put
an end to everything.
And that's a dangerous game man,
you know,
and not only because of intent but also
because of the possibility of
accidental.
Just an accident,
you know,
just,
just a mistake or just someone who's a
little crazier than you might want them
to be,
you know?
And you might think,
well no one would want to bring about
the destruction of the world.
But that just means you don't know very
much about stellan because of all the
people who lived in the 20th century who
had power,
Stalin was the most motivated to bring
everything to an end.
There's some evidence that he was
murdered by Khrushchev and his crew and
Khrushchev was the next leader.
And if he wasn't murdered,
he was at least not provided with
medical attention when he was dying.
And,
uh,
there is reasonable evidence that he was
gearing up to invade western Europe and
he didn't really care how much
destruction would go along with that.
I mean,
he'd already killed tens of millions of
people.
He had a lot of practice.
He was good at it.
It didn't really bother him.
Maybe even enjoyed it.
So what the hell?
That's what I thought.
How can it be that we're doing this?
It's so insane.
So then I started to think about belief
systems,
you know,
because you could say that each camp had
its own belief system.
The one in the West was derived.
You'd had a very lengthy history derived
from the Greeks and the Romans and Jews
and the Christians.
And,
and from various schools of philosophy
and from the enlightenment and all of
that,
and then the Soviet Union was basically
predicated on irrational philosophy
that,
that opposed the axioms that the West
had evolved and each group organized
their societies around that.
And No,
I took political science for quite a
long time
and the political scientists and the
economists,
they basically thought that people
competed over resources.
Um,
but that wasn't a very good answer as
far as I was concerned because it wasn't
obvious to me why people valued the
resources they valued.
There was the economist just assume that
there's resources that you value,
but you know,
people can value a lot of different
things.
It's,
it's not exactly fixed.
I mean you tend to value food very
highly if you're hungry obviously,
but you know,
there's lots of things that we value and
that we want that seem somewhat
arbitrary,
somewhat like a decision.
So I got more interested in why people
valued things and what it meant to value
something and then what it meant to
believe something.
And then how it could be that someone
could believe something so deeply that
they would risk their own death to
protect it or at least risk the death of
other people and maybe on a massive
scale like,
man,
people are committed to their,
to their system.
Now you know,
a system of belief is not just a system
of belief.
That's one of the things that I came to
understand is that it's not appropriate
to make this to psychological people,
defend their belief systems,
but that's not exactly right.
You know,
we have a shared belief system.
Well,
it's sufficiently shared so that here we
are,
we don't know each other.
We're a bunch of primates.
We're in this room and it's peaceful and
no one's scared.
And,
and that's pretty amazing.
And that means that we're all acting out
our roles.
So we're acting out of roles and we have
an expectation with regards to those
roles.
And those two things match.
And that's the important thing.
And we'll talk about that a lot.
It isn't the belief system or the
integrity of the belief system even.
It's the match between the belief
system.
And the actions of the other people
within the belief system,
what you want to maintain is that match.
You want to act out your beliefs in the
world and you want what you want to
happen.
That's a good thing.
You get what you want and you validate
your belief system.
Great,
perfect security,
but a lot of that is if we're
interacting even right now,
there's a whole set of expectations that
are governing what we're doing.
Like you don't want me to take your your
little tablet there and smash it.
That would be shocking,
right?
You would know what the hell to do,
You'd be somewhere different if I did
that and you wouldn't know where you
were.
And that's another thing to know because
that's a fundamental difference.
There's a fundamental difference between
knowing where you are and not knowing
where you are.
I think it's in some sense the
fundamental.
You can think about it as the
distinction between explored an
unexplored territory,
but you have to.
I don't know if you've ever taken a cat
to a new house.
Cats hate that and because in our old
house and maybe in their old
neighborhood,
they slunk around,
you know,
at the edges,
checking everything out.
They start out freight,
afraid it,
check everything out.
They know where to hide,
they know where to,
they knew,
they know what's safe and they know that
because they go somewhere and nothing
happens and so then the assuming that
it's safe and they slowly build up a
neighborhood that they're comfortable
with.
My Dad used to take the dog for a walk
and then the cat got lonesome and so it
started to follow him and first of all
it would just go along the buildings,
the houses on their route,
no hiding really from predators.
And after a while it got kind of
comfortable with that and then it would
follow right behind the dog,
but it had a border.
And if my dad took the dog over one
street too many for the cat,
the cat would just sit on the corner
and,
and you know,
cry like a cap.
Cries was like,
that's it for me,
man.
I'm not going any farther out into the
unknown.
And so the distinction between the
territory that you have mastered and the
territory that you haven't mastered is a
fundamental distinction.
It's the distinction between home and
the strange land.
And the thing about familiar territory
for people is that most of the familiar
territory that we inhabit is other
people because we're so social.
So you can't really think it's a weird
way of thinking about territory.
It's not exactly geographical objective
territory.
It's territory with a dominance
hierarchy in it and the dominance
hierarchy has a predictable structure
and you know where you fit in it most of
the time.
And so that when you act out in that
territory surrounded by your people,
then often you get what you want and
you're so thrilled about that because
you just don't want someone acting
radically around you.
Like and you know that.
So he walked down bloor and there's
people there that should really be
institutionalized,
but we institutionalize them all so they
could be free and free to be,
you know,
suffering and malfunctioning out on the
street.
That's what the freedom ended up being.
But you know,
you'll walk by someone like that who's
monitoring away to the voices in his
head,
didn't you know,
maybe
striking out against whatever it is
that's plaguing him and you will make
eye contact.
You might even go across the street.
You're certainly going to give him a
wide berth.
You're going to keep a distance between
him and you and you're going to hope
that you don't attract his attention
because he's not in the dominance
hierarchy and you don't know what the
hell he might do.
And that's unexplored territory too.
That's another way of thinking about it,
like we inhabit time and space,
not just space and not just time.
We inhabit time and space and our
territories are spacial.
Temporal.
We're here now and this is safe now and
it saved partly because of the physical
structure and it's working,
but it's also safe because none of you
are manifesting peculiar behavior.
But if you started to manifest peculiar
behavior,
if you stood up and started muttering or
yelling or maybe attacking someone next
to you,
all the rest of you would freeze first
because then all of a sudden this would
be unexplored territory,
the match between what you want,
which is a peaceful lecture that you
hope has some content,
the match between what you want and
what's happening has vanished and so
then you're not.
You don't know where you are.
And so then what do you do when you
don't know where you are?
What do you do when you don't know what
to do?
Well,
if you're a computer,
you just crash,
but
you know what good is that to you?
You're just going to die.
That isn't helpful.
You freeze first and then maybe you
cautiously cautiously attend,
or maybe you don't.
Maybe you just keep your damn eyes
averted and you sit there and you hope
that no one notices you.
That's a Predator prey response,
right?
That's like a rabbit frozen when it
thinks a fox is looking at it.
And we were prey animals for a long
time.